thinking out loud so this is what I'm
looking at okay section B this is the
first extended response so just in case
you have um if you're like me and you do
an exam and the second you leave the
exam hall all the stuff in your brain
just just goes I kinda I don't remember
any of it um let me rehearse the
question for you so that you can
remember what is about there's a
databases question to begin with a small
video store records details of its
customers and the videos and DVDs
they've borrowed
using V store a software application
which is connected to a database the
store has a single personal computer
attached to a cash drawer barcode
scanner and printer the owner of the
store uses the computer degenerate
various financial Institute's from the
database the sales staff use the
computer when enrolling new members
processing sales and entering return
movies the customer is provided with a
membership card that includes a barcode
representing their membership number
similarly each video DVD has a sticker
with a unique barcode and a separate F
possible sheet is used to process all
non-cash payments the following
incomplete data flow diagram is an
attempt to describe the information
system so copy the diagram above and
complete it by adding some labeled data
flows okay so before we get tucked in
that just delivers what was I trying to
do I was trying to we did really badly
on the time flow diagram on the previous
exam right so I wanted to bring this up
straight away but I wanted to give you a
little bit of a hand because it is the
first question out of the whole extended
response so how do I put it later
I might have just said okay we'll work
it out like I did before but this is me
kind of giving you a bit of a leg up and
saying look here are the pieces that I
want you to feel it I just want you to
give me the connections okay so the
first thing to notice is well okay one
two three four these are the processes
and you can see they correspond to what
was mentioned in the sort of a prologue
right so you want to figure out each
process I think they're kind of like the
core of the diagram and then all the
rest of it it's a little okay how does
how do they relate to each the process
okay now in many cases the process of
kind of stuck off on their own and
isolated and they don't relate to the
other processes but other times they do
okay so for instance that's how to think
about enrolling new members enrolling
new members who does the enrollment of
new members think back to the question
who's the actual person who initiates
that process then remember it's a sales
staff right and they're all the way down
here okay
now I could have been sneaky and just
giving you these icons logos right I put
them in no order okay but I actually
gave you the the way that they're
arranged is actually kind of a hit okay
because they're arranged in a way that
is probably the most logical and less
less data flows over flapping and that
kind of thing okay so the sales staff
even though they're the people who are
actually initiating this process and
making it happen okay think about what
data they provide to that process what
data do they provide that process think
carefully what data originates from the
sales staff and goes to the process have
a think
customer D does have to get entered in
right I assume you know the sales staff
Lords type you do but that kind of tells
you something right away that data
actually doesn't come from the sale
staff rate it doesn't originate from
them they might actually be entering it
in they might be the participant at that
point but they're not the source of the
data and that's what data flow diagrams
are about okay so customer details is
right but they come from surprise
surprise the customers okay so here's my
first data flow that I'm going to put it
customers they're going to provide
information to the enrollee member
process okay good morning now you could
say just customer details but kill me a
little more specific what else would we
put there I think I need probably other
markets if ITIF you said customer
details but what else could we put in
that more specifically some basic stuff
what else might they give
say that again yeah Godhead did it so
things like the dress maybe probably a
further but would do as well cool all
right
like I said I think custom idioms would
get you the mark anyway but um it's a
it's good to be as specific as possible
wherever you can and that's not that
hard to think of right okay that's the
same way as data gets provided from the
customers to this process the process
sense of data back to the customer right
think back to the question what do you
get out of this process what does the
customer receive after they enroll and
think it's not an object even though
they get an object this is just data
flow diagram so what data do they get
back yeah that's right good
okay there's the data so I'm trying to
try to tease out right if they don't get
a card back it's sorry take that back
they do get a card back but with regard
to the data flow diagram I'm not
interested in what objects they get I'm
interested in the data they receive okay
let's keep going now the enrollment of
the new member right that process it
doesn't just get data for the customer
then send it back it has to interact
with this V store this program which
this shop has right so it's not just
between the customer and this process
where would it go where would it send
some data to any suggestions
let me ask you this bless you we're the
new members enrolled right do you think
that data goes straight to the
generation of a report which the owners
going to have and then go through and
all that kind of food do you think that
would happen to me dearly but probably
not the way why why don't you think I
mean the owner is going to want reports
that include member data right but why
wouldn't it just go straight there what
you're Jack okay
store it for later use why anyone help
me out or Jack the only idea why would
they why would they do that in case you
need the member for later right I'm
trying to get a tour how busy might this
shop be actually we don't really know
right but assuming that they get quite a
few members right and then Raleigh
members constantly doesn't really make
sense to generate a report every single
time a new member is enroll right which
is why you would store the data for a
later time so where would we store it
not that many places to store it right
in this case actually you've only got
one database in the whole system so this
is where it's going yeah okay it's going
to go into that central database what
kind of things would you put their work
I'm post that to you what kinds of
things are going to go from this process
and get stored long term in that central
database what do you think
any takers what do you think drivers
yeah good um everything that was input
and output from this process it's all
going to get started here right because
not much you say taking this data and
passing it in and you've got the name
the address the phone number but when
that customer comes back with their card
and they swipe it or it gets scanned or
whatever you're like who are you I don't
know who you are because I don't know
who that number first right and vice
versa if you just stored the member
number and then they start their cars
like we're great
I recognize you as someone who has a
membership here but I don't know
anything about you okay so we would put
my suppose the member details and there
are little bit number or their ID number
ought to be a little more concise okay
let's start moving over to the right
we're talking about these reports right
now this is a really easy bit you can be
as detailed as you want but all I was
looking for is this generation of a
report okay being that it has to go
through to a database what kinds of ways
do we know to get data out of a database
we learned a whole we've spent a few
lessons on it it's like a sophisticated
language of its own what would you use
yeah you need to query right um you
don't just go out to the database and
you know ask your questions like Syria
you've got to put it in a structured
form so a query is what gets passed from
this process to the database okay does
that make sense what gets returned you
can say in report data or records either
that would be fine it's a bit difficult
to be more specific than that because it
depends on what kind of report the owner
ones right so I think you sort of have
to be intentionally vague there okay
right we're doing pretty well we've sort
of got two processes covered okay so
let's move it down a little bit